je
madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce samedi 8 décembre
avis de tempête sur la bretagne et la
normandie météo france prévoit des vents
de force 10 dès demain matin en mer la
hauteur des vagues pourraient atteindre
15 m nous ferons le point sur la carte
de vigilance c'est sur les mesures de
précaution ce soir le deuxième sommet de
l'histoire entre l'europe et l'afrique
après des années de reports 70 chefs
d'état et gouvernement sont au
rendez-vous portugal et parmi eux le
colonel mouammar kadhafi qui prendra dès
lundi la direction de la france une
visite qui suscite déjà vous le verrez
la contreverse nous irons également en
argentine où le premier ministre
françois fillon entamé une visite de
trois jours trente ans après la
dictature militaire
nous reviendrons sur le destin tragique
de deux religieuses françaises qui ont
été torturés à l'époque c'est le grand
format de ce soir c'est la nouvelle
tendance des achats de noël fini pour
certains la course aux cadeaux de
magasin en magasin
les français n'hésitent pas à faire
leurs achats sur internet
les prévisions parlent de 3 milliards
d'euros dépensés sur les différents
sites en ligne enfin du cinéma avec un
western française un nouveau genre
imaginez une ville de l'ouest américain
livrés à des enfants un scénario
étonnant avec des acteurs décapant que
vous découvrirez à la fin de ce journal
un film signé djamel bensalah et on
commence ce journal par la première
grosse tempête hivernale qui se prépare
dans l'ouest du pays météo france
prévoit que dès demain matin les côtes
bretonnes mais également normande seront
touchés par de fortes rafales de vent
des vents qui pourrait atteindre plus de
130 kilomètres heure en mer des vagues
de 15 mètres de haut sont également
prévues et les bateaux ont déjà pris la
direction des ports depuis quelques
heures le point ce soir avec amaury
guibert rentrer au port dès que possible
un impératif sur la côte atlantique aux
sables d'olonne les secours en mer était
d'ailleurs déjà à pied d'oeuvre
on était
c'est donc par le par le cross etel pour
porter assistance à un bateau a été
remorqué par un autre bateau c'est de le
keops c'est un bateau de morlaix et qui
était de nos rangs il est plus de deux
moteurs quoi sur les côtes du finistère
aussi les bateaux se pressent pour se
mettre à l'abri de temps en temps
l'océan donne le ton de la journée de
demain une journée en alerte orange avec
risque de gros coup de vent sur un quart
nord ouest du pays
la zone la plus concernée va du
finistère à la seine maritime
dans ces départements les rafales de
vent pourront atteindre 140 km heure sur
les côtes les plus exposés en mer on
attend des vagues de 15 mètres
mais le dispositif de secours est en
place le remorqueur abeille bourbon ces
pré positionnés à l'entrée du rail
d'ouessant
il sera épaulé par ce navire l'argonaute
qui croisera lui au large de brest
la plus grande prudence est aussi de
mise sur les routes
il faut éviter les déplacements en
particulier sur les axes côtier au delà
de 10 mètres ce qui est fort possible
une vague et sourds se mélanger et peut
emporter un véhicule donc il suffit
d'une dune occasions et malheureusement
c'est chez la mauvaise donc ne pas
prendre ce risque surtout pas plus pas
pour soi et encore moins pour les autres
un conseil de prudence qui vaut aussi
pour les promeneurs souvent attirés par
le spectacle de la mer déchaînée
un spectacle grandiose mais dangereux et
la première conséquence donc de cette
tempête ce sont des mesures de prudence
vous l'avez compris éviter les bords de
mer attention sur les routes des pluies
pourront également accompagner ce fort
coup de vent alors comment prendre
connaissance des zones à risque et bien
météo france a mis en place depuis
quelques jours un nouveau système d'
alerte pluie inondation un système
accessible sur internet
l'explication jérôme berlin christine
beauce jean pierre pasteur 6 septembre
2005 le département du gard a été placé
en état de vigilance rouge
plus intense plusieurs centaines de
litres au mètre carré nîmes est
partiellement inondées le lendemain la
vigilance face à l' orange des pluies
deux fois moins importante
pourtant la nuit suivante les zones
inondées se multiplient incompréhension
de la population pour qu ils alertent
était partiellement levé la vigilance
météo ne prend pas en compte les sols
gorgés d'eau et les crues potentiel
c'est à partir de cet exemple qui a été
imaginé un nouveau système d'information
si vous allez sur le site de météo
france
soyez attentifs à ces petits
pictogrammes ils apparaissent dès qu'un
département est placé en vigilance
orange
d'un seul clic ils renvoient des
informations plus précises et pas
seulement pour le grand public
c'est un enjeu est également important
pour les mères dont je rappelle qu'ils
sont la première autorité de police sur
leur territoire et qui leur appartient
par leur expérience aussi qui est qui
riche qui est importante expérience de
plusieurs années d'inondations de mieux
prévoir et d'anticiper les conséquences
que pourrait avoir pour telle route pour
telle école pour tel camping une
quantité d'eau qui est annoncé par météo
france
ici à la préfecture de l'hérault on
teste le système depuis un an on espère
le perfectionner encore en intégrant la
nature des sols par exemple et pour
toutes les informations météo vous
retrouver et bien sûr isabelle martinez
dès la fin de ce journal
un coup de vent et la houle qui serait à
l'origine du naufrage d'un bateau sur le
bassin d'arcachon à wall-e a été
retrouvé échoué sur une plage de lège
cap ferret deux hommes étaient portés
disparus un corps a finalement été
retrouvé aujourd'hui au bas de la dune
du pilat les recherches ont été
suspendues en raison du mauvais temps
ils sont près de 70 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement réunis pour un sommet
europe afrique pourtant à lisbonne au
portugal
ce sont deux hommes qui attire
particulièrement l'attention d'abord le
président du zimbabwe robert mugabe
interdit de séjour dans l'union
européenne en raison des violations des
droits de l'homme de son régime et autre
personnalité controversée présente au
portugal le futur invité de la france -
marc kadhafi sur place françois
beaudonnet c'est son grand retour sur la
scène internationale à lisbonne le
colonel kadhafi ne cache pas sa
satisfaction au moment où il entame une
tournée européenne qui le mènera à paris
lundi car derrière le dirigeant libyen
créé
evènement il demande dédommagements pour
la colonisation et il semble justifier
le terrorisme international
des déclarations qui n'empêche pourtant
pas nicolas sarkozy de venir le saluer
chaleureusement
et malgré la pluie de critiques que
provoque en france la visite de mouammar
kadhafi le président de la république
maintient ce soir sa position si nous
n'accueillons pas des pays qui vont qui
prennent le chemin de la respectabilité
que devons nous dire à ceux qui prennent
le chemin inverse et j'ai dit au
président kadhafi que j'encouragerai ce
retour vers la respectabilité
internationale autres dirigeants très
contesté robert mugabe 87 ans
officiellement interdit de séjour en
europe pour violations des droits de
l'homme le président du zimbabwe qui
musèle l'opposition dans son pays a été
ici vertement critiqué par la
chancelière allemande à lisbonne tous
les sujet qui divise l'europe et
l'afrique auront donc été abordé mais ce
sommet aura aussi montré que 50 ans
après la décolonisation
la plupart des plaies restent ouvertes
et la visite du président kadhafi
commencera donc dès lundi suscite déjà
des commentaires ainsi pierre moscovici
le président socialiste de la commission
denquête sur la libération des
infirmières bulgares estime que cette
visite est tout simplement le véritable
prix de leur libération
on écoute je trouve que cette visite est
un excès d'honneur
je crois que c'est une reconnaissance
d'un régime qui reste encore un régime
douteux
le colonel kadhafi certes fait une
évolution par la communauté
internationale il elle sert te renier
par exemple les ambitions nucléaires qui
ne pouvaient avoir ou combattu le
terrorisme mais il reste encore un homme
très très ambigu et je trouve que ce
nouvel ami de nicolas sarkozy est bien
payé pour avoir pendant des années des
années torture et des femmes torturé un
homme
il ya encore des hommes et des femmes
qui sont torturés dans ses geôles
françois fillon est en argentine et il
représentera la france lors de la
passation de pouvoir entre le président
sortant nestor kirchner et son épouse
cristina qui a été élu
28 octobre dernier le premier ministre
qui rendrait également ce soir hommage à
buenos aires à deux religieuses
françaises enlevés torturés et exécutés
par la junte militaire à la fin des
années 70 zine dine boudaoud et mathieu
dreujou vont vous raconter leur destin
tragique
c'est le grand format de ce samedi la
trace des deux religieuses françaises se
perdre en 1977 à l'école de mécanique de
la marine un centre de torture sous la
dictature soeur léonie duquet et sera
lice d'oman ont sans doute été
assassinés toutes les deux cinq mille
personnes dans l'île a pas story ça on
était torturé ici c'est l'une des rares
survivantes
cette militante de gauche a vu léonie
duquet
peu de temps avant sa mort à cet endroit
précis
elle m'a dit qu'on était dimanche le
jour du seigneur qu'il fallait prier
on a parlé à rabat elle s'inquiétait
pour ce rallye c'est ma demande et que
lui ont ils fait qu'elles y ont ils fait
elle est là pour couvrir son crime le
régime militaire fabrique une fausse
preuve une photo des deux religieuses
sous une banderole des montoneros la
guérilla d'extrême gauche
ce montage est censé innocenté la junte
au pouvoir
celui qui a fabriqué la banderole c'est
lui
prisonnier on l'y a contraint après la
photo ricardo coq et n'a plus jamais
revu les deux religieuses il les avait
surnommés les petites soeurs volantes
on a compris qu'elle avait été jeté d'un
avion les restes de léonie duquet ont
été identifiés en juin 2005 dans une
fosse commune mais pas ceux d'alice
domon léonie duquet repose dans le
jardin d'une église de buenos aires leur
bourreau surnommé l' ange blond de la
mort c'est luis alfredo astiz un
officier de la marine déjà condamné à la
perpétuité en france
paris demande son extradition mais il
doit aussi être jugé dans son pays ni
lui ni son défenseur me répondent aux
journalistes son avocat ignore que notre
caméra l'enregistrent le capitaine astis
n'était pas présent quand les deux
soeurs françaises sur mitraillette et
soeurs bombe atomique ont disparu
elles sont intervenues dans la situation
argentine alors qu'elle était étrangère
elle n'avait rien n'à ferris yvonne
pierron a échappé de justesse aux
griffes du capitanat stis
elle partageait l'engagement de ce
rallye c'est soeur léonie aux côtés des
pauvres
à 79 ans elle vit toujours aujourd'hui
en argentine que survivant j pour
témoigner avec la vérité et je dis
toujours il n'ya pas besoin d'exagérer
d'exagérer parce que c'est passé parce
que c'est tellement monstrueux avec la
pure vérité c'est déjà monstrueux
l'argentine encore du mal à regarder son
passé en face les mères des disparus les
folles de mai n'ont jamais été folle
mais elle tourne toujours pour la vérité
l'ex-capitaine alfredo astiz doit
maintenant répondre des crimes dont il
est soupçonné devant la justice de son
pays
ce procès attendu avant la fin de
l'année sera surtout le procès de la
junte militaire et de ses méthodes
barbares
les familles des victimes réclament la
vérité depuis 31 ans en france justice
avec le verdict dans la sphère du bus
incendié de marseille après trois heures
et demie de délibéré hier soir les
peines prononcées vont de 5 à 9 ans de
prison les peines équilibre est
accueilli dans un climat plutôt apaisé
retour sur ce verdict avec stéphane
despinoy et michel commun la cour
d'assises dès mineurs a créé la surprise
hier soir elle n'a pas lourdement
condamné les jeunes incendiaires les
familles s'attendait à bien pire
on attendait 30 13 en ce sens soulagé
c'est beaucoup sa fin
j'essaie mieux mais 31 mai au 15 mai +10
1 celui qui a avoué avoir lancé le
mouchoir enflammé et condamné à 9 ans
l'avocat général en avait requis quinze
retenue qu'elle jugeait des mineurs et a
retenu que leurs agissements aux causes
et des conséquences involontaires
puisqu'il n'avait pas choisi de faire du
mal physiquement à quiconque le jeune
ayant reconnu avoir jeté de l'essence
dans le bus écope de sept ans les trois
autres poursuivi pour avoir notamment
bloqué les portes de sept quatre et
trois ans ferme
l'avocat du 6e a le sourire son client
est acquitté selon la défense c'est un
verdict nuance la justice des mineurs a
été réhabilité dans ce procès c'est
capital je dire que les jurés des
bouches du rhône et les et la cour
d'assises l'a ont été absolument fournir
sans être laxiste
toujours dans la retenue la famille de
mama galedou n'a pas commenté le verdict
est l'accès c'est que ma main et sa
famille de mal et dès le début s'était
délitée justice nous souhaitons que de
tels actes mais selon conduisent plus
jamais et son cousin lance un appel je
pense qu'au moment où corps pour son
rétablissement a besoin de prières de
tout le monde et nous demandons à tout
le monde de continuer à prier pour elle
pour l'aider à guérir rapidement et
fortement informé du verdict mama
galedou a dit à son avocat pour moi
c'est fini dans ma tête mais un autre
procès s'annonce les deux plus jeunes
condamnés par le tribunal pour enfants à
huit ans de prison au mois de septembre
comparaîtront à nouveau en appel en
février dans l'enquêté sur la sphère du
colis piégé qui a fait un mort jeudi
dans un cabinet d'avocats parisien
l'homme qui avait été placé en garde à
vue quelques heures après les faits nie
toujours son implication dans l'attentât
selon la police sont de 10 y en aurait
pour l'instant apporté aucun progrès
dans l' enquête
le procès colonna n'est définitivement
pas un procès comme les autres après
quatre semaines d'audience les juges de
la cour d'assises les avocats des
différentes parties et l'accusé se
rendront donc demain à ajaccio un
transport onéreux placée sous très haute
surveillance pas moins de 500 policiers
et gendarmes seront mobilisés
un déplacement pour quelles raisons
explications olivier théron dire j'ai
llado le préfet erignac est tombé ici
trois balles dans la nuque le 6 février
demain la cour d'assises spéciale les
magistrats les avocats yvan colonna
l'accusé du meurtre viendront voir les
lieux il ne s'agit pas d'une
reconstitution mais d'un déplacement
demandée par les avocats d'yvan colonna
il espère étayer leur défense prouver
qu'il n'y avait que deux tueurs et pas
trois comme le soutient l'accusation
c'est toute une logistique qui a dû se
mettre en place plus de 500 policiers et
crs sont mobilisés pour sécuriser les
lieux et assurer le huis clos comme dans
une salle d'audience on se trouve dans
le cadre de la loi de 1881 qui est le
même que dans une salle d'audience c'est
à dire qu'il est interdit de capter
d'enregistrer et ensuite de diffuser une
image de la cour d'assises en ce qui
concerne l accusé vous savez qu'il ya
des textes qui prévoient qu'il est
interdit de diffuser l'image d'une
personne qui est entravée pour yvan
colonna arrêté il ya quatre ans ce
retour en corse même dans ces conditions
sera particulièrement éprouvant la cour
arrivera en transall à l'aéroport
d'ajaccio avant de se rendre à pied 3 l
c'est ici que l'armé qui a servi à tuer
le préfet erignac a été dérobées lors de
l'attaqué de la gendarmerie
ensuite les magistrats iront rue colonna
d'ornano à la tombée de la nuit pour
avoir la même luminosité que le soir du
meurtre
demain ici il y aura des projecteurs
surpuissants dirigés sur les façades
pour débusquer les journalistes des
bâches pour protéger la cour et yvan
colonna une ambiance d'état siège pour
essayer de mieux comprendre ce qui s'est
passé lors de l'assassinât du préfet
erignac
la police dans la rue aujourd'hui à
paris c'est au cri d'officiers en colère
que plusieurs milliers d'entre eux ont
manifesté
ils craignent en devenant quatre lettres
par exemple moins bien rémunérés pour
les heures supplémentaires effectuées
manifestation organisée à l'appel du
syndicat national des officiers de
police
autre manifestation à paris toujours
avec cette fois celle des militants anti
publicité il critique notamment la
distribution à buzy
tracts notre équipe a d'ailleurs voulu
vérifier pour l'occasion l'état de nos
boîtes aux lettres sont elles toujours
autant veille de pub en tout genre une
campagne de sensibilisation avait déjà
été lancée il ya trois ans alors at elle
était utile pas vraiment reportage
françois je lis un pied noir et
christophe vignal c'était tellement
tentant de commencer notre reportage
comme ça un peu exagéré non pas tant que
ça quand on sait que chaque année une
boîte aux lettres aval 40 kg de
publicité en france c'est un million de
tonnes de papier distribués puis
direction la poubelle et il faut ensuite
recyclés à l'heure actuelle les
distributeurs ne contribue qu'à hauteur
de 15 % du coût total qui ce qui qui
prend en charge le traitement et la
collecte
donc non payant 3 85% ce coup du coup
c'est la taxe sur les ordures ménagères
que tout le monde paye en fin d'année
premier dans nos boîtes aux lettres les
catalogues des grandes surfaces malgré
l'autorisation de faire de la pub à la
télé rien n'a changé toujours autant de
papier 2e les journaux des petites
annonces suivi par le commerçant du coin
qui fait sa pub dans le quartier pour
empêcher l'intrusion publicitaires en
2004 un autocollant stop la pub faisait
son apparition sur quelques boîtes qui
nous avons suivi ce distributeur pendant
sa tournée
ces quantités papiers n'ont pas baissé
car trois ans après le lancement de
l'autocollant seulement 5% des
particuliers l'on connaît il peut y
avoir des erreurs c'est très en effet
jamais les erreurs parce que on a une à
l'ordre et on a le le le devoir de ne
pas m'être papier devant devant une
voiturette qui porte un seau pure et
pourtant selon une étude une fois sur
deux l'autocollant n'est pas respectée
mais contrairement aux idées reçues 83%
des particuliers me recevoir de temps en
temps la promotion du boucher ou une
réduction pour un canapé
les achats se font prématurément et
avant tout chez eux à la maison
tranquillement
hier soir
elles sont faites à les faire nommer la
gèrent leurs courses avec eux à
prospectus à la nar liste de courses
déjà très établi en ce mois de décembre
difficile de faire marche arrière
d'échapper à l'avalanche de papier noël
approche avec son lot de catalogues et
publicité c'est l'actualité du moment
les courses de noël sont pour certains
un vrai plaisir mais pour d'autres c'est
tout simplement une corvée bien afin
d'éviter d'arpenter des magasins de plus
en plus de personnes choisissent la
solution internet
elles passent leurs commandes derrière
leur écran d'ordinateur l'an dernier
plus de 2 milliards d'euros ont été
dépensés pour les achats de noël sur le
net un record à battre pour cette année
caroline thébaux alexio il ce cross est
encore là texte sur les cadeaux mais une
chose est sûre les achats se feront
tissement le appelé parce qu'il a finie
la foule des magasins
cette famille commande tout sur internet
carangues largement ça nous permet aussi
d'avoir un choix beaucoup plus large que
simplement je ou trois magasins qu'on
aurait en fait très peu de temps d'aller
voir pendant le week-end de comparer les
prix beaucoup plus facilement et puis
surtout d'être vraiment sur des
disponibilités d'une part et puis
d'aider les livraisons l'écran pour
faire du lèche vitrine
une tendance qui bat des records cette
année un français sur trois devraient
acheter une partie de ces cadeaux sur
internet 3 milliard d'euros seront ainsi
dépensé 20 % de plus que l'année
dernière
jouer mais aussi champagne foie gras
aujourd'hui on peut préparer noël sans
sortir de chez soi
succès garanti pour ce site internet qui
vont des produits de marque à moitié
prix 7000 commandes par jour c'est trois
fois plus que d'habitude plein profil
type c'est une femme 25 45 ans qui
habite dans les grandes agglomérations
mais aussi dans les petites villes et en
province pour quoi elle retrouve des
produits via le média internet qu'elle
ne retrouve pas localement en coulisses
les salariés des sites internet
s'activent ici sur 35 mètres carrés se
trouve le palmarès des produits phares
de cette année consoles de jeux gps
télévie
ou un écran plat le client doit être
livré en 24 heures une somme d'environ
35 milles à 40 mille commandes par jour
soit 3 à 4 fois une journée normale de
l'année pour un mois de décembre car
d'après 20% d'un type d'affaires chaque
client dépense en moyenne 200 euros
reste à 'acheter' soi même les papiers
cadeaux l'industrie nautique se porte à
merveille et pourtant en france les
ventes de bateaux sont en baisse -3% en
2007 la raison est étonnante les ventes
seraient en fait tout simplement freiné
par le manque de places dans les ports
il en manquerait environ 50 milles à
l'heure face à ce constat les idées ne
manquent pas pour trouver des solutions
léo lamberton françois privat en temps
normal la scène dure 4 minutes 4 minutes
durant lesquelles ces pontons mobiles se
déplacent entraînant avec eux les
bateaux qui sont amarrés ils sont
télécommandés depuis la capitainerie du
port
une première mondiale c'est cette panne
alors qui va s'ouvrir ce système de
pontons mobiles est installé depuis
juillet au cap d'agde dans l'hérault
coût 1 millions d'euros mais grâce à lui
le fort n'est plus engorgées et de
nouvelles places de bateaux ont été
créés si nous n'avions pas eu ces
pontons mobiles
nous aurions dû faire une installation
classique à savoir conserver un espace
de manoeuvre pour chacun chaque
printemps est là nous aurions donc perdu
un bon temps et donc 32 places il manque
actuellement en france 50 milles à nous
pour accueillir les bateaux et pour
gérer la pénurie
chaque commune a sa solution stockage au
sec comme ici à palavas les flots ou
totale réorganisation du port comme aux
sables d'olonne en vendée
là les pêcheurs se sont regroupés et
pousser au faire de la place aux
plaisanciers
ça m'a permis d'avoir une place que
j'étais en listes d'attentes sur le port
de plaisance
et
encore attendre trois quatre ans il faut
avouer que 120 places de plaidant
supplémentaires en plein coeur de ville
aux sables d'olonne
c'était une opportunité qui avait et qui
a été saisie en fait aujourd'hui en
france on assiste à une course de
vitesse car les plaisanciers sont
souvent inscrits sur les listes
d'attentes de plusieurs ports et le
premier qui arrive à dégager des places
est aussi le premier à gagner de
nouveaux clients
la saison de ski commence
progressivement ainsi serre-chevalier
courchevel ou encore chamrousse ont
ouvert leurs portes ce week-end idem
pour isola 2000 où le soleil était au
rendez vous aujourd'hui sur place
nathalie jourdan et niels brunelli de
l'été ils ont gardé la pause et les
lunettes
mais c'est tout c'est bien beau la plage
et puis on entend de suite les soldes
d'hiver où la neige a basket ball hiver
et plus grand chose à faire aller au
bout dit c'est normal c'est la première
descente de la saison
neuf mois qu'ils attendaient ça
alors même si la neige est un peu dur
après une si longue attente forcément
les fresh & desseauve c'est génial le
paradis sur terre un paradis où l'on
oublie l'essentiel un paradis un peu
trop pentu mais c'est comme ça alors
vous verrez la ddcs et c'est pas
difficile
et voilà que plusieurs ex 15 cm en bas
des pistes soient sont au sommet
suffisant pour ouvrir une partie du
domaine ce qui est ouvert est
parfaitement skiable oui elle attend non
on peut pas attendre
c'est le premier jour déjà ça doit être
le week-end dernier mais nous sommes
très en colère que ça n'avait pas été le
week-end dernier quoi des clients
exigeants qui ont la mémoire un peu
courte
c'est vrai que l'année dernière on a
ouvert une semaine plus tard dans des
conditions nous le permettent
les gens veulent skier il trépigne en
base sur nice donc aujourd'hui c'est
parfait dans le coin il se murmure que
d'autres pistes et devrait bientôt
ouvrir parole d'ancien il va beaucoup
neigé cette année sport avec tout
d'abord la boxe brahim asloum bref ce
soir de conquérir un titre de champion
du monde en poids mi mouche
une catégorie qui lui avait porté chance
aux jeux de sydney et pour y parvenir
après deux échecs mondiaux le boxeur
français a n'a pas lésiné sur les moyens
il a même perdu 11 kg pour revenir dans
cette catégorie alors peut-il être
performant après de tels efforts
reportage à hontanx dit et zidane
berkous des pieds à la tête il ne pèse
plus bien lourd hier à l'heure de la
pesée pour obtenir une nouvelle chance
mondiale
brahim asloum a dévoilé son corps émacié
moins de 49 kg une main serait un poids
qui suscite de nombreuses interrogations
et ici je te fait toucher mes abdos g10
et des pierres condamné pascal et l'ado
à partir de là je peux pas dire que les
affaiblit du juge journée du jus
peut-être nous verrons ce soir du
courage c'est sûr car après deux échecs
pour décrocher un titre mondial et
quelques larmes
le français a décidé de changer de
catégorie en moins de trois mois il a dû
maigrir de 11 kg passant de 60 kg sur la
balance à moins de 49 kg résultat d'une
intensive cure d'amaigrissement qui a
fait perdre aux français près de 20 % de
son poids total 10 à tous les sportifs
de se réhydrater régulièrement pendant
leur épreuve d'endurance là à ce moment
là ce serait inverse on partirait déjà
déshydraté catastrophe en effet en terme
de force musculaire en termes
d'endurance
et puis on peut faire notamment des des
crampes depuis son sacre olympique il ya
sept ans asloum court toujours après un
titre de champion du monde
à bientôt 29 ans le produit marketing a
du plomb dans l aile et le problème
c'est que nos français va affronter un
argentin au mental d'acier
travaillant dans les champs dès l'âge de
13 ans l'adversaire fait donc le poids à
soumet ses kilos en moins tant que ce
soir un dangereux coup de poker dans le
reste de l'actualité sportive laure
manaudou battu sur 400 m la coupe
d'europe de rugby
l'om qui s'impose face à monaco et la
victoire des françaises handball tour
d'horizon avec nathanaël de rincquesen
s'est pas encore l'euphorie des grandes
victoires
mais cet après midi l'équipe de france
de handball n'a pas boudé son plaisir
qu'au terme d'un match équilibré les
françaises ont pris le meilleur sur la
macédoine un succès 29 23 qui leur
assure une place en quarts de finale
à quatre jours de son duel décisif face
à liverpool l'om s'est offert une cure
de confiance cet après midi au vélodrome
dans le rôle du sparring partner monaco
n'a pas pesé bien lourd
deux buts en deuxième mi temps marseille
prend ses distances avec la zone de
relégation
quelques jours de noël clairement offert
un joli cadeau à ses supporteurs trois
essais et surtout une belle victoire sur
les london wasps champion d'europe en
titre
les clermontois sa pause 37 27 et
conservent toutes leurs chances de
qualification au nettement moins
inspirés toulouse a offert sur un
plateau le premier essai de son match
face à leicester
une petite erreur une grosse conséquence
les toulousains s'incline 14 9
le match retour sera animée depuis deux
ans elle est la porte drapeau du
biathlon français depuis deux jours elle
est inarrêtable
une victoire hier une victoire
aujourd'hui sandrine bailly occupe
désormais la première place du
classement général de la coupe du monde
dans le flou chez ces médias aux
championnats france laure manaudou
poursuit tranquillement son retour au
premier plan
cet après-midi la championne olympique a
remporté le 200 m nage libre presque
sans forcer
c'est son 48e titre de championne de
france la routine quoi
la crise au paris saint germain avec
cette conséquence folle conséquence
puisque jérôme rothen qui étaient en
froid avec certains supporters a fait
l'objet de menaces très graves dans la
nuit de jeudi à vendredi à son domicile
son véhicule a d'ailleurs été endommagés
le joueur déposé plainte et la police a
choisi de protéger l'international
français paris se déplacera demain à
auxerre pour un match à nouveau sous
haute tension la page cinéma de ce
samedi soir avec un film français
familiale est vraiment original big city
signé djamel bensalah il a choisi de
renouveler le western en donnant la
grande partie des rôles de son film à
des enfants mais attention il ne s'agit
pas uniquement d'un film où l'on rit
souvent
on y parle injustice raciste écologie on
y revient dans un instant avec deux des
héros du film tout d'abord le reportage
de marie jo jouant et jean-marie
lequertier les rôles de ce western à 10
ans l'âge moyen des jeunes acteurs de
big city après six mois de tournage au
canada et en bulgarie il assure la
promotion du film en province par petits
groupes
ici à lyon il raconte l'histoire de
cette ville abandonnée par les parents
ou les enfants se retrouvent livrés à
eux mêmes avec une seule compagnie un
ivrogne et l'idiot du village
le postulat du scénario donner à des
enfants les rôles et les mots d'adultes
pour mettre en exergue le racisme et
l'intolérance du monde
les bombardiers ici les indiens
représentent l'étranger la différence du
mali
il a bien non c'est un film miroir sur
nos comportements d'adultes c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est de se dire voilà
j'utilise ces enfants pour faire
finalement il ne s'agit pas des adultes
mais il nous vraiment jette au visage
tout nos maladresses toutes nos
malveillance toute nouvelle tous nos
défauts mais si moi tawang à croire
et les communicants il ya pire ici est
le thème cowboys et indiens cohabite
avec plaisir dans le film c'est une
autre histoire
il est pas il réfléchit pas et n'est pas
poète il est pas au quai alors qu'un
indien ça réfléchit plus et l'ignoble
tout ça
actif sur ainsi qu'un seul donc céline
faye mais on sait que c'est du cinéma
donc je sais pas voilà tous vous
embrasser mes biens tirs
tous ces jeunes acteurs ont apporté leur
fraîcheur leur bon sens et aussi leur
sens inné de la justice même sur scène
pourquoi certains ont été doublé pour
les cascades et pas les autres mois
double alors avec nous deux des héros de
big city vincent valade dont 13 ans et
charlie quatrefages dix ans bonsoir à
tous les deux comme ça je voulais vous
poser une question d'abord charlie
honneur aux filles ça vous dérange pas
non non vous jouez une entraîneuse de
saloon djamel bensalah vous a très vite
a très vite expliqué les choses tu
expliquer ton rôle il a expliqué ce
qu'il fallait faire là en fait je le
savais déjà
ah c'est vrai après demain petit peu
précis les deux ou trois choses mais
sinon je savais déjà ce n'est pas
surprise non alors à vos côtés il ya
vincent alias john wayne alors c'est qui
james quinn s'est tu joues le héros en
fait en quelque sorte là c'est le héros
de l'histoire le gentil du film celui
qui sauve tout le monde voilà il sauve
tout le monde mais il a quand même
il a un côté très naïf en fait c'est un
khlifi y voit pas trop quand les filets
mais il n'a pas les yeux encore de
l'amour quoi là et vous finirez par
tomber amoureux l'un de l'autre
peut-être dans la réalité alors charlie
big city c'est plutôt un film comique on
rigole ou pas seulement je dirais pas
seulement parce que c'est vrai le goal
com vous avez dit tout à l'heure vous
pris à des yade et on tire des leçons de
morale deux heures en gare
aussi des façons d'apprendre à vivre et
qui à la fois aussi on va dire que c'est
émouvant
et puis il ya de l'action on m'a dit
charlie chan
parce qu'il ya un peu de tout puisqu'il
ya des moments on rigole mais aussi des
moments assez du roucan autres il ya des
choses de la vie ray comme le racisme
on parle aussi de l'écologie des choses
comme ça donc moi je pense que c'est
avec quelques belles voitures voilà il
ya des messages aux tensions
alors vous êtes et 80 enfants je crois
sur le tournage a duré six mois
il s'est mis souvent en colère de m
bensalah bah ça lui arrive une ou deux
fois mais sinon c'était pour les scènes
parce que sinon il s'énerve et pas en
dehors des scènes et vous rigoliez un
petit peu quand même en avoir
c'était comme une colonie parce que 80
enfants sur un plateau c'est près d'une
colonie de vacances en fait alors je
crois que même certains des enfants
perdaient leurs dents je crois qu'il ya
eu une histoire comme ça en fait là
pendant une répétition j'ai perdu mes
dents et du coup tu es un mail il a
envoyé le tout le monde chez le dentiste
rendu compte qu'on avait des landes
belle et donc perdu autant à moi c'est
pas ça c'est qu'en fait comme il fait
rendu compte hier n'est qu'avec lé
perdre leur dans leur a fait faire
tomber leur donc plus tôt que prévu et
moi même voix la magie comme
d'impertinence un tournage alors on vous
a vu tous les deux à l'avant première
vous avez découvert ce film vous l'aimez
ce film bah j'ai trouvé bien mais d'un
autre côté quand on joue dans le film on
n'a pas un regard très extérieur donc
c'est un peu difficile de juger les
films en fait qu'elles ont lieu
plusieurs langues
1 quand on joue dans comment les autres
les jeux dans à la fois c'est bien puis
des fois on n'est pas trop concentré sur
l'histoire mais plutôt contre un
concentré sur les acteurs non sur vous
voir et vous trouvez pas mal oui patron
fin ah bon mais encore une fois je
trouve tout le temps qu'un joue mal en
fait dink bah moi c'est pareil inquiète
pas
envie qu'on peut toujours faire mieux
est ce que vous voulez vous avez envie
de continuer ce métier je crois que
c'est pas à votre premier film
moi je fais trois téléfilms et trois
fils jean-louis j'ai fait une pièce d'un
court métrage et de téléfilms donc ça
sinon vous allez continuer nous allons
enfin oui enfin on n'a fait que quelques
films donc on sait qu'on n'a pas une
carrière toute tracée
oui on espère mais on verra bien on
verra bien en tout cas merci à tous les
deux on ira voir ce film big city en
tout cas voulez bien vous ai bien fait
la promo mais avec le coeur merci
beaucoup c'est un film a pas manqué en
famille ça sort mercredi un peu partout
en france musique c'est l'un des grands
rendez vous de l'année en bretagne les
transmusicales de rennes le festival a
toujours eu du nez pour découvrir les
nouveaux talents
c'était le cas pour etienne daho encore
la mano negra alors quelles seront les
artistes de demain sur place olivier
nizza et josé où le sexe à rennes la
musique c'est un peu comme au cinéma il
y a des projecteurs et il ya les
vedettes des chanteuses venues de
belgique
l'été dernier philippe katerine les
invita à ses côtés sur scène car l'homme
les adore
là
les vedettes ici ans majoré philippe
katerine et est depuis hier en coulisse
venu encourager ses côtés j'ai indiqué
aux transmusicales première tranche
musicale mais je sais pas parce que je
n'étais jamais venu et nous que nous est
tombé dessus comme ça elles n'ont jamais
si bien porté leur nom dans l'oeil des
photographes
aussi je viens quand tu m'as dit à cette
année à rennes
les filles sont à l'honneur ils ont été
trop longtemps médicaux c'est la
revanche des talons aiguille talent ou
monsieur apprécié kate nash est né à
dublin via nombre 4 nages découverte
grâce à internet
moi
les adolescents succombe enregistrait
des chansons sur mon ordinateur portable
et maintenant je suis ici dans tous les
pays où je passe des gens me connaissent
vraiment dingue
hier à rennes c'était un peu le paradis
des filles
dans quelques mois kate nash aura la
fiche des plus grands festivals
il faudra alors je des coudes pour
assister à ses concerts au premier rang
des images pour finir de la célèbre fête
des lumières à lyon ce soir toute la
population de la ville et les touristes
peuvent profiter de ces illuminations du
commun à des lumières des couleurs
surprenantes un événement unique en
europe plus de 70 spectacles lumineux
sont proposées au public avant de
refermer ce journal je vous rappelle
qu'il ne faut pas hésiter à composer le
36 37 durant tout le week-end vous
pouvez apporter vos dons au combat
contre les maladies génétiques
il s'agit du 21ème téléthon et sachez le
la recherche avance grâce à vous
également
charlie d'un sens et vous faire quelque
chose ce soir c'est très français
ça peut détruire l'orateur ça a été
assez bien la merci à vous voilà pour
l'actualité de ce samedi
merci à vous d'avoir suivi journal dans
un instant ne manquez pas la météo il
avait le martin et avec cet avis de
tempête
20h50 la grande fête du téléthon
présenté parce qu'ils avant et nagui
demain midi france de frites avec denis
balbir je vous retrouve à 13 heures
passé une très belle soirée et à demain
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr